y
[Música]
segundo oro para francia la judoca a
clarisa que viene no ganó su primera
medalla dorada olímpica la final de judo
femenino tenemos reporte con esta
enviada especial a los juegos olímpicos
de tokio en hong kong un joven de 24
años de edad de ser el primer condenado
con la polémica ley de seguridad
nacional dong jin kit fue encontrado
culpable de terrorismo incitar a la
secesión tenemos detalles del juicio
desde beijing
seúl y pyongyang retomaron los canales
de comunicación luego de 13 meses de
silencio ambos líderes acordaron
reestablecer la confianza mutua y
desarrollar sus relaciones lo antes
posible la comunicación entre ambas
naciones fue cortada unilateralmente por
pyongyang
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 serra blanco y como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
con noticias que nos llegan desde tokio
porque la francesa claris acv en en judo
ganó su primer oro olímpico en la final
de judo femenino desde la capital
japonesa nuestro enviado especial
natalia ruiz con todos los detalles
yaiza me dio la primera medalla de oro a
francia la judoca de 28 años ganó en la
categoría de menos 63 kilos en una final
que disputó ante la eslovena más 30 en
regla misma ayudó cante la que se tuvo
que enfrentar en la final en río 2016 y
ante la que había perdido en esa ocasión
muchísimas lágrimas momentos de emoción
se vivieron aquí en el nippon budokan en
tokio tras esa victoria francesa otro
que se convirtió en campeón olímpico
esta vez en surf fue el brasilero ítalo
ferreira tras vencer al japonés canoa y
garage la medalla de bronce fue para el
australiano override quien venció a otro
de los favoritos otro brasilero gabriela
medina y debo decirles que la final del
surf fue absolutamente espectacular muy
palpitante debido a las condiciones
climáticas que trajo consigo un tifón
que está atravesando por japón el agua
que también ha traído varias medallas
más a brasil bueno otra más esta mañana
en la final de 200 metros libres fue
fernando saber quién se quedó con la
medalla de bronce con un tiempo que
además le permite tener récord
nacional la medalla de oro la medalla de
plata fue para la dupla británica
también y duncan scouts
cambiamos ahora información porque
protestas a favor y en contra del
gobierno cubano se desarrollaron en
varias ciudades del mundo luego de las
manifestaciones del pueblo cubano contra
el régimen comunista que comenzaron el
pasado 11 de julio es el caso de madrid
buenos aires y ciudad de méjico decenas
de personas se concentraron frente a las
respectivas embajadas para pedirle a
miguel díaz scanner a miguel díaz canel
el fin del embargo estadounidense contra
la nación caribeña en parís en la sede
diplomática cubana fue atacada con tres
cócteles molotov que provocaron un
incendio en la fachada y del que el
gobierno cubano ha responsabilizado a la
administración estadounidense por sus
campañas contra la isla
un tribunal de hong kong condenó a tong
jin kit de 24 años en el primer juicio
con la polémica ley de seguridad
nacional jim kit fue encontrado culpable
de terrorismo e incitar a la secesión
más de 60 personas han sido acusadas
bajo la controversial ley incluidos
algunos de los más reconocidos
activistas prodemocracia desde beijing
nuestro corresponsal
adrián foncillas con todos los detalles
de 24 años trabajaba en un restaurante y
será recordado como el primer condenado
por la ley de seguridad nacional de hong
kong el joven ha sido declarado culpable
esta tarde de los delitos de incitación
a la secesión y terrorismo y los
próximos días se dará a conocer su
condena que podría alcanzar la cadena
perpetua la sentencia condenatoria se
daba por descontado porque los hechos se
habían quedado grabados en unas imágenes
que dieron la vuelta al mundo el joven a
bordo de una motocicleta de gran
cilindrada arrollo a los tres policías
que intentaban detenerle y les causó
graves heridas así que el debate
jurídico se centraba en la bandera que
estaba llevando en esos momentos
en la que se leía liberal hong kong la
revolución de nuestros días uno de los
eslóganes más célebres de las protestas
violentas de la anterior entre una ha
sentado que se abandera incitaba a la
secesión uno de los delitos más graves
según la nueva ley bajo esa ley aprobada
por pekín hace 13 meses se ha detenido a
138 personas y se han presentado cargos
sobre 76 así que es más
en los próximos meses veamos un caudal
de duras sentencias condenatorias
seguimos en asia azul y pyongyang
retomaron los canales de comunicación
luego de 13 meses de silencio y tras
varios intercambios de cartas el
surcoreano muniáin y el norcoreano kim
jong-un acordaron mejorar los lazos la
comunicación entre ambas naciones fue
cortada unilateralmente por pyongyang en
rechazo por el envío de propaganda
contraria al régimen por parte de
activistas desde el sur veamos el
informe jalisco un funcionario de corea
del sur habló con el norte en la línea
directa intercoreana por primera vez
desde junio del año pasado
dado que ahora se han restablecido las
líneas de enlace de comunicación
intercoreanas espero que podamos seguir
dando buenas noticias al resto del mundo
la presidencia de corea del sur dijo que
los dos líderes muniáin y kim jong-un
habían decidido normalizar las
comunicaciones fronterizas como primer
paso para mejorar sus lazos dando un
chance a los líderes de las dos coreas
han estado intercambiando cartas en
múltiples ocasiones desde abril para
comunicar
entre sí sobre el tema del
restablecimiento de las relaciones
intercoreanas en el proceso acordaron
restaurar primero las líneas de
comunicación que habían sido cortadas
la agencia estatal de noticias de corea
del norte lo describió como un gran paso
en la recuperación de la confianza mutua
y la promoción de la reconciliación y
que contrasta con la del 16 de junio de
2020 cuando corea del norte hizo
estallar una oficina de enlace conjunta
que estaba vacía en la ciudad fronteriza
de kaesong pyongyang se molestó por el
fracaso de seúl en detener a los
activistas que lanzaron folletos en su
contra a través de la frontera los lazos
bilaterales se estancaron después de una
segunda cumbre fallida en febrero de
2019 entre kim y el ex presidente de
eeuu donald trump una cumbre a la que
moon se había ofrecido a mediar los
expertos dicen que piensan ahora está
buscando mejorar las relaciones
transfronterizas antes de una posible
reanudación de las conversaciones con el
gobierno de bailén y el deseo de ver una
flexibilización de las sanciones
internacionales en medio de la crisis de
kobe 19
[Música]
y el presidente tunecino defendió sus
acciones frente a quienes lo acusaban de
haber orquestado un golpe de estado'
caixa y dijo que tenía el derecho
constitucional de despedir al primer
ministro y de suspender el parlamento
mientras tanto el partido islamista
enhada principal fuerza legislativo y
socio del primer ministro destituido
aceptó celebrar elecciones anticipadas
con el fin de proteger la democracia a
evitar un régimen autocrático el
presidente de caixa it sostiene que todo
tiene legitimidad y ha negado las
acusaciones de que su decisión de
despedir al primer ministro y suspender
al parlamento equivale a un golpe de
estado
he asumido la responsabilidad estoy
asumiendo una responsabilidad histórica
aquellos que afirman que este asunto
está relacionado con un golpe de estado
deben revisar sus lecciones en la
constitución talca no
se ha visto a la gente a no salir a las
calles prometió que cualquier oposición
violenta se enfrentaría con la fuerza y
también reforzó las restricciones de
kobe 19 en cuanto a reuniones el primer
ministro destituido y james y se acordó
dejar que el presidente eligiera su
sucesor diciendo que no quería causar
problemas más temprano el lunes
estallaron refriegas frente al
parlamento de túnez cuando los
partidarios del presidente se
enfrentaron a los partidarios del
principal partido del país las
decisiones del presidente de caixa y no
son correctas contra la constitución y
la realidad nos traen de nuevo a 1954
ver el parlamento cerrado por tanques es
una vergüenza la decisión se tomó luego
de meses de estancamiento político y
crecientes tensiones el impacto de la
pandemia junto con el alto desempleo
resultó en protestas masivas contra el
gobierno durante el fin de semana muchas
potencias extranjeras han expresado su
preocupación por las acciones del
presidente esa y instando a túnez a no
poner en peligro su democracia de 10
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
confirmó que las tropas de su país
dejarán irak a final de año aunque
permanecerán en esa nación un número
indeterminado de soldados para asesorar
y entrenar al ejército iraquí sin
embargo bailén no especificó el número
de efectivos que se quedarán en irak
para continuar la lucha contra el grupo
estado islámico y para hacer frente a
las milicias chiíes aliadas con teherán
y que en los últimos meses han
incrementado sus ataques contra tropas
estadounidenses
el cardenal angelo betún que en el
pasado fue uno de los hombres más
poderosos del vaticano y estrecho
colaborador del papá francisco será
juzgado desde hoy en un proceso
histórico sobre corrupción será la
primera vez que un cardenal se siente
ante el tribunal del estado ciudad del
vaticano lo hará junto a otras nueve
personas acusadas de malversación de
fondos blanqueo de dinero fraude y abuso
de poder en el caso de que investiga una
irregular inversión de unos 350 millones
de euros en un edificio de londres
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo france24 continuar con
nosotros con día
[Música]
muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
esperan cada semana